Speaker 1: All right.
So we're going to kind of close our coverage
of this wacky weekend in Alaska.
We looked at the Trump rally.
We looked at Sarah Palin.
We're now going to look at some interviews
with rally attendees.
And one of the things we realized was that
Trump supporters in Alaska are just as delusional
and just as disconnected from reality as those
in other parts of the country.
Alaska often gets this reputation, sort of
like Vermont, of being a different type of
place where left and right don't mean the
same things and the Republicans are more reasonable
and the liberals are more conservative.
You know, all these different things because
of it's rural and all these stuff, maybe to
some degree that that's true.
And in fact, I think it is true to some degree,
but no shortage of whacked out delusional
participants, I guess, in the political system
here, some women are asked what are the main
issues that are of concern to you, the main
political issues, women in Alaska, what are
you worried about?
I'm not going to preview what they say.
Let's listen to what they say.
Speaker 3: What's the most important issue
that you guys are concerned about as Alaska?
Oh, spacebar.
Sorry.
Q are killing the support of our veterans.
The healing.
I'm sorry.
Trafficking.
Specifically, what kind of trafficking?
Human trafficking.
Are you worried about?
Our southern border?
Yes, everything.
I think eventually they'll end up going back
to their own countries with massages are kicking
in that right now.
Speaker 1: There's a lot there.
So the main issues for women in Alaska, conservative
women, principled conservative women are space
force, which is doing nothing right now.
QR codes killing people, I think, is what
she said.
Veterans.
Okay.
Healing.
Healing is great.
But from what?
And in what way?
Trafficking and the southern border of the
United States, which is quite removed both
geographically and politically from what's
happening in Alaska.
Alaska, of course, sharing a border with Canada.
These are the issues that they say are the
most important.
Now at the end.
You might have heard that this woman mentions
niece Sara and just Sara.
Speaker 3: Going back to the old countries
with massages are kicking.
Speaker 1: In.
Okay.
When that I watched that on Saturday during
our stream.
I didn't know what on earth this woman was
talking about.
NAZARA is an acronym for the National Economic
Security and Recovery Act.
These were some proposed economic reforms
suggested during the 1990s by a guy named
Harvey Francis Barnard who wanted to replace
the income tax with a national sales tax and
get rid of compound interest unsecured loans
and go back to a currency backed by two types
of precious metal, you know, all these different
things.
And it's kind of become a cult like thing.
And the idea that people are going to go back
to Mexico because of Nassau, I mean, it is
so out there that even many conspiracy theorists
have no idea what it's about.
So that's what women in Alaska say they care
about.
Here is a guy who is sort of a medical marvel.
Listen to this guy's voice.
He seems to have something in his throat.
Not it not is not his mouth.
Not his nose, but his throat.
I've never heard someone speak like this in
an extended way.
I asked some doctor friends of mine what exactly
is going on here.
They said they don't know this.
What you're about to hear is defying the medical
knowledge of multiple doctors.
Check this out.
Speaker 2: Look what he did for us.
I mean, come on, man.
He's a he's a business man.
He shows him people up.
Speaker 1: I can't even pretend to speak that
way.
Speaker 2: They can't.
They don't know where they're at.
Cause he knows.
And going out of business, he got all of our
prices down, our taxes down, our gas down,
our food down.
To manage your dream.
Speaker 1: Now, not only did Trump not do
any of those things, I tried holding water
in my mouth to try to sound like that.
I tried sort of like speaking through a gargle.
I could not replicate that.
And what a wild, wild day in Anchorage, Alaska.
So the supporters also crediting Trump with
things he didn't do.
Imagining new conspiracy.
I mean, it just completely all over the place.
And we have to remember, some of these people
vote.
Not all of them.
Some of them show up at these rallies.
They travel all over going to rallies.
And they say they're devoted to Trump.
They're like, I was working that day or I
wasn't working.
I was just doing nothing and I didn't go and
vote.
This group of folks will determine who controls
the House and Senate after January of 2023
based on how they vote this November.
So wild, but not to be ignored as a political
constituency.